quel est pour vous le meilleur film de
princesse la petite sirène il y a ça ou
dernièrement Mulan alors Mulan ça m'a
scotché non mais c'est vrai parce que
c'est hyper féministe Mulan mais c'est
génial non j'ai pleuré devant Mulan je
suis enceinte je suis un peu fragile
mais j'ai trouvé que c'était ouais que
c'était un super beau film de princesse
justement parce que bah avant de devenir
princesse elle sauve son pays et puis
avec une arme que les voilà qui qui est
l'intelligence dans une dans une
civilisation où les femmes sont
considérées comme vraiment des
accessoires donc j'ai trouva que c'était
un très beau film quel est pour vous le
meilleur prince charmant de cinéma je
suis en hésitation entre Ryan Goslin
Jake
gillenhole on se fait plaisir hein ou
c'est qui le trè que j'adore récemment
oh là là edard Norton dans
burnman ah je l'ai adoré quelles sont
pour vous les plus belles conasses du 7e
art Scarlet
Ohara Cléopâtre Mery strip dans le
diable s'abille en Prada la dame de fer
aussi je crois quel est le film culte de
la
marrylionire quel est votre film culte
j'hésite entre
parrain Snatch Dar Jing Limited
et et
KillBill c'est un éventail un peu large
mais tu sais siis parti sur une î désert
je prendrais cela quoi quel est le film
qui vous a traumatisé durant votre
enfance les dents de la mer
définitivement j'ai un gros problème des
Dents de la mer c'est non mais c'est
vrai c'est affreux ça m'a vraiment j'ai
du mal à aller loin quoi au large alors
qu'avant j'adorais nager avant de voir
ce film j'étais vraiment comme un po
poisson dans l'eau et là vraiment je
suis là je dis bon
jetir quel est le film qui vous fait
systématiquement hurler de rire Louis
finess me fait systématiquement hler de
rire dans tous ces films avez-vous une
réplique de cinéma que vous aimez
utiliser dans la vie no Body Perfect
Certains l'aiment chaud quel est pour
vous le film le plus sensuel à part les
Films
Porno en fait j'adore quand quand quand
le quand le baiser tu vois quand le
quand on te fait monter le désir et que
tu vois c'est installéas tellement envie
qu'il s'embrasseou autre quel acteur
vous a donné vos premers Mo amoureux
Ahou on est très quand Mme plis Leonardo
DiCaprio dans Titanic je peux pas c'est
vraiment d'une banalité affigeante mais
c'est vrai je suis allé le voir trois
fois
et alors que maintenant il est pas
terrible il est excellent mais pas
terrible quelle est l'actrice qui vous
touche le plus Blanchette j'adore
Blanchette quel est l'acteur qui vous
touche le plus en fait ça dépend des
films tu sais à chaque film mais le
dernier en date c'est ARD Norton dans
dans burnman quelle est votre principale
qualité sur un plateau l'envie quel est
votre principal défaut sur un
plateau la table
régie avec quel acteur ou actrice
rêvez-vous de tourner j'aimerais
beaucoup tourner avec Meril strip et
Leonardo
DiCaprio la pauvre groupie quoi
j'aurais pu dire au Diar j'aurais pu non
j'ai dit
DiCaprio quelle personnalité disparu
auriez-vous aimé croiser sur un tournage
Freddy
Mercury quel est votre personnage de
cinéma préféré je sais pas je me
souviens que j'avais adoré rine brokovic
par exemple
ou alors complètement dans un autre
genre hly Hunter dans la leçon de piano
j'ai pass c'est des grands rôles
féminins qui ouais tu vois qui sont qui
sont des partitions magnifiques quel est
votre principal plaisir professionnel
euh jouer non mais c'est vrai quel autre
métier auriez-vous pu ou aimé faire ben
je me suis souvent posé la question dans
des moments de désespoir je me disais
vraiment comment comment en couple je
puisque c'est comme ça j'arrête alors là
c'est bon je disis qu'est-ce que je vais
faire qu'est-ce que j'aimais faire
d'autre benah rien bon ben tant pis je
vais souffrir un peu puis partir
avez-vous un rêve ultime toujours porter
des belles
robes c'est pas que ça s'arrête
jamais tu
sais
voilà je je je trouve que les actrices
qui tournent jusqu'à jusqu'à la fin de
leur vie moi aujourd'hui ça ça ça me ça
sera un rêve que penserait la
de cette interview euh
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sinon